weak and wobbly that's the focus of
tonight's
[Music]
angle this is how little the
progressives fear and respect the leader
of their party when he's overseas in a
tweet directed at Biden Rashida T
referred to the Israeli Hamas conflict
as your war and accused our Ally Israel
of bombing the hospital and today she
doubled
down just continue to watch people think
it's okay to bomb a hospital
we're children I can cry we all can cry
President Biden not all Americans with
you on this one and you need to bre up
and understand
[Applause]
that slave obviously holds Biden in
utter contempt she's certainly not
afraid of any political consequences
from him but then again why are we
surprised this is the problem that Biden
is facing everywhere because everyone in
the world knows that he's weak and that
the the US is weak under his leadership
and filling this vacuum are America's
adversaries leaders from 140 countries
oh that's all are gathered in Beijing to
celebrate the 10th anniversary of
China's trillion dollar belt and Road
initiative Putin's there because he
believes XI is a serious man and that
China is the future now it was no
accident that their statements Russia
and China's criticizing Israel and
demanding a ceasefire almost seem
coordinated take the other side against
America after all gave them an
opportunity to band together and show
the world that America's on the down
slope and Iran under Biden they feel the
same way they're not overly concerned by
America's warnings those people just
gave him6 billion dollar heck even the
president of a NATO country Victor Orban
of Hungary he seemed perfectly at ease
appearing with Putin and Beijing
yesterday now might he have thought that
would offend the White House he clearly
doesn't care but under Trump
none of them were so Cavalier about this
kind of stuff during Trump's presidency
XI rushed to meet at Mar Lago in the
spring of 2017 and Trump bombed Syria
during dessert Putin wanted a closer
relationship with the United States but
the Deep State they made sure that never
happened with the phony Russia kusia
stuff he never would have tried taking
Ukraine we all know this if Trump were
president he would not dare strength
gets results remember it was because of
Trump that NATO countries finally pledge
to spend more money on their military
Canada and Mexico they agreed to revamp
NAFTA because Trump's team knew how to
exercise leverage do it from a position
of strength but now both our allies and
our adversaries know that America is not
looking out for America so they don't
respect us we don't respect ourselves
they don't respect Biden they don't
respect his top advisors either they
look at someone like a Janet Yellen as a
nice old lady more interested in sucking
up to China than protecting her own
country's economy they look at Tony
blinkin and they see a small weak man
easily pushed around just a few days ago
a total snub by the Saudi Crown Prince
humiliating Biden uh blinkin excuse me
by making him wait several hours before
he finally met with him at his farm
residence now some of this might seem
like small ball but in the world of
diplomacy small gestures speak
volumes
but presidents who are considered
generally our best presidents have been
able to unite Americans and defend our
national interest they had gravitas and
were passionately
pro-american ask not what your country
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country Mr
gorbachov tear down this
war in the 20th century Americans got
used to the idea that the president
would represent our interest in the
world and would explain coherently the
challenges that we all face doing that
would then Inspire confidence make us
all more willing to sacrifice actually
excited to sacrifice especially in the
foreign policy Arena where so much is at
stake but unfortunately the media and
the unelected bureaucracy in Washington
they think that having a figurehead
president is just fine after all it
gives them more power and influence this
morning in Israel it looked like blinkin
was in charge
but has Tony blinkin ever intimidated
anyone in his life look at Jake Sullivan
the National Security adviser's comments
about how things were really calm in the
Middle East a few weeks ago now under
the best of circumstances and I'm saying
the best of circumstances where we had a
president and a cabinet able to deafly
assess the situation this would be a
really tough needle to thread but with
this guy asked the Secretary of State
when he and I are working in the Senate
to write something for man said uh he
wrote a line that uh I think is a
appropriate he said uh it's not we lead
uh not just uh well I won't go into it
I'll wait to later taking too much time
oh my gosh watching this I'm thinking
the poor Israelis have had to stand to
listen to this haven't they suffered
enough and imagine what the Press would
say if a Republican president injected
himself into the middle of an unfolding
crisis then referred to the barbaric
terrorists who spurred it spared on this
way I was deeply saddened and outraged
by the uh explosion at the hospital in
Gaza yesterday and based on what I've
seen it appears as though it was done by
the other team not not you but there's a
lot of people out there not sure so we
got a lot we got to overcome a lot of
things was he sleep sleeping the other
team they would crucify Trump if he said
anything like that if he acted that that
way in fact the global chaos though that
we're seeing under Biden remember that
is exactly what the regime media said
when they predicted Trump would create
this madness around the world president
Trump has essentially minimi minimized
or sublimated the idea of the us as kind
of the underpinning of a rules-based
international order president Trump
we've had bad presidents before bad
foreign policy presidents we have
absolutely hit bottom and it's it's
frightening Donald Trump is really
ruining and destroying American foreign
policy yeah
well what are we seeing around us
now peace and calm are they breaking out
all over the place with Joe Biden as
President we had peace When Donald Trump
was president but now the Middle East is
on fire Ukraine's in the middle of a war
but for Reagan it was peace through
strength remember for Biden is chaos
through weakness or actually that's much
too much for him to remember so my
message to any state or any other
hostile actor thinking about attacking
Israel Remains the Same as it was a week
ago don't don't
don't the press as usual dutifully
campaigns and covers for him the
Democratic president United States
attempting to conduct Global diplomacy
attempting to be in some ways a
peacemaker in the Middle East he is out
there representing the United States of
America and of course the historians
open up a second line of defense
president's now done this twice uh he
went to Kei this is a remarkable moment
uh in the history of the American
presidency for a president to go this
soon into this kind of climate Joe Biden
went to both places in the middle of a
in the middle of a war risked his life
to try to bring some order to the chaos
the truth is and they all know it Biden
did not go to Israel because he's strong
he went to Israel because he's weak and
he's desperately trying to resurrect his
failing presidency by playing Peacemaker
While most of the important players are
just ignoring him and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else